[Music]
what happened
um i was getting a taxi and
i just finished a show i was gonna go do
some karaoke with a buddy
get a little backstreet boys going and
uh
yeah i was opening the taxi door and we
got rear ended as i was halfway out
oh my god it's like every time i think
about it like i clench
like my butt cheeks clench because it's
just the way that i was twisted
my head hit the inside of the door frame
three times and
like the neck injuries that go with that
too because like a whiplash is like a d
and so that's three head hits and then
the neck injuries right away because my
spine was twisted
it jabbed into my nerves down my spine
like my own spine injured me basically
and
my hips like my si joint ended up out of
place and my hips were out of alignment
my one leg is
visibly longer than the other one it's a
talent now
uh party track i can kick higher here
and uh
yeah so basically that's what happened
we got hit there when i was halfway out
and it ended up in being like tmj
that was so bad i was crushing my own
teeth in my sleep and waking up without
teeth
i'd swallow them uh it was so bad i
couldn't put a spoon in my mouth to eat
when i got to tmj i got so skinny like
there's photos of me even a couple years
ago i look emaciated
like i just look emaciated and people
thought i was dieting i couldn't eat
because i couldn't chew they went from
head injury as well which was
that was probably the hardest part when
i think of it other than the physical
pain is not remembering my address
being somewhere and forgetting how i got
there
getting into the shower and knowing
something feels off
but i don't know what and i was fully
clothed in the shower
and i didn't know like i couldn't put
those two and two together i'd put my
keys in the fridge
uh there's all these weird little
cognitive things that were going on
and then getting over that and then
having to deal with the physical pain
because i would
shake like i had parkinson's for most of
the day i'd be sweating through my
sheets every night
multiple times a night like i'd have to
change my sheets mill the night